الرابع عشر من مايو تاريخ يحمل ثقلان في
تركيا انتخاباته
1950 التي انهت حكم الحزب الواحد التاريخ
قد يعيد نفسه نفس الموعد قد يكون ربما اهم
موعد سياسي في تاريخ تركيا الحديث استخدم
اردوغان صلاحيته من اجل اختيار هذا
التاريخ للانتخابات بدلا من الثامن عشر من
يونيو والهدف الترشح لولايه ثالثه
والمبررات الموسيقه كثيره واهمها تجنب
موعد الامتحانات الجامعيه وتزامن الحملات
الانتخابيه مع شهر رمضان والدور الثاني من
الانتخابات انحدث مع موسم
لن يغامر باصوات المحافظين لكن الاجابه
الصحيحه تاتي من الدستور يسمح للرئيس
بتقديم الانتخابات مده 60 يوما لاغراض
تنظيميه لكنه لا يمتلك صلاحيه تحويل اسمها
لانتخابات مبكره ترشح ولايه ثانيه ثالثه
يتطلب موافقه البرلمان على منح صفه
الانتخابات المبكره وهنا عائق تركيبه
البرلمان تمرير هذا القرار يحتاج موافقه
360 صوتا من اصل 600 صوت وحزب العداله
والتنميه الحاكم يمتلك
286 مقعدا فقط الباقي للمعارضه التي وافقت
على الموعد الجديد لكن رفضت اعتبارها
مبكرا معركه خاسره اذا بالنسبه لاردوغان
ولذلك رفض هو تسميتها بالمبكره وهذا يضعنا
امام السيناريو الثاني قراءه مختلفه
للقوانين لحزب اردوغان تقول المعارضه
دستور 2017 اقر انتخابات مبكره اقيمت عام
2018 وبذلك يعتبر ترشحان هذه المره يندرج
تحت اطار ولايه ثانيه لا ثالثه في كل
الاحوال لن تقف التشريعات عائقا امام
اردوغان وحزبه والسنوات العشر الماضيه
اثبت ذلك وهنا سيناريو الثالث مشاهدينا لو
رفض البرلمان قبول ترشحه قد يقدم على حله
في اي وقت واقامه انتخابات مثيره
قد يحدث فوضى دستوريه لا شك وبينما تشير
استطلاعات الراي الى تقدم اردوغان على
احزاب المعارضه الا ان حمى الانتخابات
اشتدت بسبب عدم حسم ملايين الناخبين
لقرارهم خطاب اردوغان بالدرجه الاولى موجه
نحو الاتراك المحافظين المنتمين للتيار
الديني وهم مسانده تقليديا قوانين الجنسيه
انجبت لاعبا جديدا حصول 270 الف اجنبي على
الجنسيه جعلهم كتله انتخابيه هامه يصعب
على المعارضه استقطابها اما المعارضه
فتحاول كسب اصوات الشباب ثمانيه وعشرون في
المئه منهم يعانون من البطاله ولم
يستفيدوا من اجراءات رفع الاجور اصوات
النساء بدورها باتت متارجحه بعد ان سحب
التركيه منذ ايام من اتفاقيه اسطنبول
لحمايه المراه المدن الكبرى باتت مفتوحه
امام المعارضه اسطنبول ازمير وانقره باتت
تحت حكم المعارضه تعداد سكانها مج يمثل
ثلث سكان البلاد وبينما يواجه اردوغان
خطابا قويا في الداخل لا تتردد المعارضه
في كسب ود الخارج فعمدته اسطنبول اكرم
امام اوملو اكد ان المعارضه ستعمل على
بناء علاقه متميزه في منطقه البلقان